ein älterer mann sitzt im lehnstuhl und
erzählt wie er damals im corona winter
2020 zum helden wurde
wenn wir auf unsere marge zu hause und
kämpften gegen die ausbreitung des
chores mit nichtstun
damit wird die bundesregierung
neuerdings für das zuhause bleiben in
der korona krise und erklärt im video
die nichtstuer zu helden der clip sorgt
in den sozialen medien für
unterschiedliche meinungen
die entertainer joko und klaas teilen
den clip mit dem hashtag stay home auch
moderator kai pflaume ist begeistert und
der regierungssprecher steffen seibert
teilt den link mit dem hashtag besondere
helden
kritik übt die grünen politikerin renate
künast mit diesem tweet deutlicher
kritisiert hier die piratenpartei die
junge leute zu hause bleiben sollen
wenn sie doch in die schulen gehen
müssten statt aufhören unterricht
umzusteigen
der nordrhein-westfälische
ministerpräsident armin laschet findet
den spot besonders das ist eine
ungewöhnliche pr maßnahme die wirbt
dafür vorsichtig zu sein und die regeln
einzuhalten und zu hause zu bleiben
im informationsfilm sei die couch zur
front geworden die geduld zur waffe
diese analogie findet der bayerische
ministerpräsident nicht ganz treffend
sind immer noch wie ich selbst bei der
bundeswehr war und wir ihm gewarnt
worden wie lange die zeit wäre bis man
sozusagen einen panzer überleben könnte
oder einem lkw den ich beispielsweise
dort gefahren habe insofern kann man das
immer nicht vergleichen
trotz der kritik ein brillantes spot
twitter journalist sascha lobo manche
leute erreiche man eben nur so mehr
nachrichten um breaking news nur bei der
schau dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren